and it's great to see you all here today
with us
so uh this symposium is extremely
important for us and i hope you all are
as excited as we are to hear about these
cutting edge approaches in life sciences
and also omics space
um we will learn about these challenges
not just from our team but from experts
who have spent their lives struggling
with these challenges and more
importantly coming with coming up with
these great solutions
also it is great to see a much broader
appreciation of data in life science
domain as well as a great excitement
about this potential impact of
bioinformatics on areas touching the
lives of everyone for example medicine
vaccine design genomic surveillance and
even space travel
so in this presentation i will explain
our initiatives and highlight the
partnerships and collaborations for
omics logic bioinformatics and data
science training research in asia and
upcoming expert sessions and discussions
on day one of this omics logic
fall research symposium
so let me start uh by taking this
opportunity uh to briefly introduce
myself and our team
since 2019 we have launched omixlogic in
india with initial collaborations at
several universities where we piloted
our training and worked with faculty to
develop programs that addresses the
major gaps in bioinformatics education
so since then we have been working with
thousands of students from our partner
universities who are going through this
training and working on projects so we
will be discussing that so working in
project work and faculty who are
interested to utilize this collaborative
research platform to incorporate
bioinformatics or project-based
bioinformatics and data science
curriculums so tell you to tell you a
little bit more about this growth and
about our collaborations so we have been
able to work with a lot of students and
that's why it has been a thrilling
journey and this experience has enabled
us to work on variety of challenges that
comes
with the educational training as well as
the translational aspect and the
translational research so with the
agenda to bring awareness about
data-driven healthcare research our team
is reaching out to
sorry reaching out to universities to
make bioinformatics and high quality
data driven research accessible to
everyone so this engagement has helped
also helped us to collect a lot of this
data and improve on our learning models
so after many programs coordinated with
universities thousands of students
across india
we saw that there is a gap there is a
gap in skills there is a gap that
student
help effectively could integrate into
their research project thinking
critically about the data applying
appropriate methods to the right data
these are some of the gaps which are
quite evident uh which we were able to
find out and propose solutions to so in
this presentation i'll be taking you
through those uh through those case
studies and also the solutions that we
have got and the innovation that we were
able to bring into this
so um every student we started with this
realization and with this goal that
every student needs to be enabled with
data skills and analysis logic to
succeed in their research to succeed in
their academia excel in their career and
to be ready for the world of data we now
live in so schools universities and
colleges they needed to be equipped to
help faculty and students learn and use
data now
this is a big task
and hence it is a big task on our hand
that can only be accomplished or
achieved by a community not by only us
by a group of people group of
like-minded researchers group of
like-minded institutions and and
universities and uh our appreciation
really to all of our academic partners
who have come forward and joined hands
to bring this awareness to bring these
new tools to bring this new technology
and an international standard to the
training and research that we are
providing in collaboration so
not only industry not only academia but
also industry and that that is why we
are here today to discuss what can our
educational system do about this gap how
do schools colleges and universities
prepare students for the future of
biotechnology and life science in
general so where biology we can see that
like this is quite evident because we
see that every day that biology is
acquiring the characteristics of data
science we are generating so much data
how can we merge data science and life
science together in a practical way that
is effective as well as inclusive how to
prepare students for successful research
and industry career give them skills and
experiences that help them navigate
their future so this is something that
we have learned and that that we have
experienced through our own own journey
as well as through the entire experience
of working with these thousands of
students and we are delighted and have
welcomed all our industry collaborators
those have really contributed in this in
mentorship in industry translation
transition and soft skill development in
translational projects for expert omix
logic fellows internships and job
opportunities career guidance and
placements research opportunities and
also startups and hackathon hackathons
so there is a lot of contribution about
through industry through academia and we
are seeing these different components
here and there
so
during this entire symposium we will be
able to do one thing we will be able to
connect these components together and
see that how this could be a part of uh
it could be an ecosystem in itself
so to do to be able to do that that
brings me to this slide
where we would want to uh make a
major announcement for our 2020 fall
semester and that announcement is the
launch of omixlogic partnership
university program and this this unique
or this program was developed by
contributions not only by the team but
subject matter experts from our
partnership partner universities and
research institutions that you just saw
on the previous slides
not only them but also thousands of
students who have completed the omics
logic training and have provided this
valuable feedback so this omixlogic
partnership is a unique opportunity for
universities and is a comprehensive and
a flexible program designed to help
students faculty and industry to succeed
in this age of data
so our homologic training is designed to
make complex topics like bioinformatics
machine learning
and system medicine easy to incorporate
into existing curricula and help
students and faculty transition to the
data driven research projects where
bioinformatics curriculum curriculums
are designed based on the need and the
level of participants focusing on the
personalized level of training
personalized level of uh help that
many of the students require or many of
us required to get the best outcome to
work on and to be able to apply
bioinformatics data science biomedical
data science and some of those topics
so we prepared this very unique
curriculum along with our partners which
is now available for anyone any
university to opt for free uh is to uh
use these topics which are not usually
if are the part of their curriculum so
the omics logic training again is a
personalized training and research
experience that enables participants to
develop critical scientific thinking
utilizing modern bioinformatics and data
science practices on industry relevant
problems so the sessions that we have
designed they introduce statistical
methods visualization introduction to
popular machine learning techniques for
omix data analysis participants do learn
about public data repositories and
various file formats that are used in
bioinformatics for storing and
efficiently processing omics data so uh
as i was discussing all of this to you i
think the best way to do this is through
a
practical experience and that practical
experience is the case study that i
wanted to discuss with all of you today
so uh a memorandum of understanding an
mou was signed between mit university
uttar pradesh and pine biotech u.s for
joint research and training in the area
of areas of bioinformatics and data
science all right so this collaboration
helped us pilot the omics logic research
based training on a diverse student
cohorts coming from a non-bioinformatics
background applying data science for
biological problems
now this could only again be possible
with the help of a team so the the
collaborative partnership
program or this partnership that we have
just launched enabled all our partners
to work uh work together while sharing
ideas while sharing research proposals
while sharing curriculums or curriculas
that are protected by the agreement
between these three organizations so the
first organization amity university
uttar pradesh pine biotech and our major
academic partner topper bioinformatics
research center at the university of
haifa in israel so scientists from the
center are providing academic oversights
and guidance in curriculum preparation
development of current bioinformatics
analysis uh on the tbanfor platform as
you have seen as a as you we just uh
did that uh saw that sunalika discussing
about that that allows
non-bioinformaticians to run complex
algorithms on large-scale databases and
uh
and the
support team uh whom who have been uh
working relentless to help students go
through these different stages of
training uh uh
through um online and virtual as well as
uh on-site
support
now
to be able to do this uh we would ne we
would be needing a
way to evaluate students evaluate their
journey so to learn about the progress
of student during the training and to
learn about the challenges as well as to
encourage students to move through these
different stages of training we
developed and utilized a point-based
system that integrates bloom's level as
sonalika was telling you and helped us
create a dynamic and a unique interface
ever in bioinformatics and a great
experience for the users now uh we have
the platform that could enable uh and
encourage students and now what we would
want is a pipeline to be able to help
students go through this different
stages that i've been talking about so
to do this uh one of the things and one
of the challenges or i could say the
next challenge for us was to develop the
right components get to get a meaningful
outcome from this training experience so
the reason the reason is that many
students and it's an experience working
with students from all around the globe
they need a soft landing into this field
of bioinformatics where they can get
introduced to the application of
bioinformatics through projects and gain
access to the community with mentorship
guidance and structure so these are some
of the components that are required at a
basic beginner level so we develop these
different stages and resources basic
training example projects and coding so
these are different stages you start
with the basic training you move to
example projects and you learn coding
and and then you practice to work on
projects by practicing on various data
sets and algorithms finally you
are ready to work on your own research
projects or a faculty driven research
projects a research project so that is
the pipeline that we prepared and
created
to be able to
help students who are coming from
different uh backgrounds different
knowledge and different interests
now
uh
in the next few slides uh i'll discuss
about the outcomes of the partnership
training program that enables our team
to meet face-to-face
face-to-face and addresses address gaps
and work together and find solutions to
the challenges and translate ideas into
actionable tasks and outcomes so uh this
is again an experience and this is one
of the
one of the pilot that shows it's a case
study that shows that how this route has
helped us develop these outcomes that
i'm going to show you in the next few
slides
so
as i was telling you about some of these
points integration of new ideas that is
very important
because of this opportunities
applicable of this
open source data and then application of
new technology in life science and then
you know kind of becoming an expert to
be able to contribute to this ongoing
scientific
advancements these are really exciting
uh exciting opportunities for students
for faculty who opted this field to
contribute actually for the human
well-being right so the omics logic pro
training had
was able to provide these opportunities
not only to the few but the entire
cohort of students and the
simplification with the simplification
and the integration of ngs and omix
technologies and algorithms through the
training
now
as i'm talking about integration
integration of next generation
sequencing homes technology data science
algorithms and that is one of the focus
of our company and uh and then uh to be
able to do this uh we were able to work
together with the faculty with the with
the administration and develop
curriculums that has industry insights
so we are looking at job opportunities
we are looking at what is that that
industry is looking into these
candidates or these students and then we
are trying to highlight that through the
curriculum and that is the industry
insight that we are bringing to the uh
to the curriculum of this uh
universities now uh the last component
of all of this the last component of all
of this is to
be like first you learn and then you
apply and then you do a research project
then you gain experience from a project
and to be able to work in a group learn
those soft skills communicate how to
communicate in a group and to you know
how to make a meaningful way to showcase
your research do a presentation and do a
publication but after all of this what
is that is needed is the job opportunity
or the next opportunity that you are
looking to that could be a program that
could be a master's program that could
be a phd program or that could be a job
opportunity so finally to get job and
internship opportunity to build
excellent profiles on omixlogic portal
for recruiters and startups we
integrated
this
the omics logic job opportunity port
into the portal and that helped us to uh
to the to guide students directly to the
related opportunity with the skills that
they are working on and gaining so um
the partnership university program uh as
as discussed is to simplify the training
and make it accessible to students from
all background and not only from all
background but from all uh
demographies from low income countries
and from places where it is really
difficult to access
technology access infrastructure this is
entirely online and we are offering the
basic training which is the stage one of
this pipeline freely to the interested
universities who wants to pilot the
training for their students and
to tell you about the research aspect of
all of this and one of the major outcome
is to be able to work on thus the aspect
of your doing doing your own research
and working on your own research idea or
how a faculty can work on a faculty can
propose their research ideas and the
students can
help with their skill sets to overcome
some of the challenges in in their own
research so one of the important aspect
of all of this is to be able to help
students gain those skill sets and to be
able to come up with uh complete a
project because many students and we
it's it's also us that we tend to start
many things and then to complete that
and to finish that and publish that it
takes a lot of time there are different
stages here this it gets complicated and
there's a lot of research and there is a
lot of literature review and
there are different aspects of of
research so uh to overcome these
challenges we developed this research
fellowship training where we were able
to help student uh work from any remote
area at any at their convenient time
working on industry designed example
projects that we curated and then mentor
guidance uh with group projects that are
from phd and post doctoral level
solution providing phd and post doctoral
level solution so we have dr
raghavendran and we have a huge
community here who are helping us guide
the students with their independent
research proposals and integrating
faculty ideas into a research project
now
the students who were able to
do that where
we're the ones who benefited from this
and uh also the the faculty who were
able to uh
work with us collaboratively are also
some of those uh who have benefited from
this research work and now uh to tell
you about the
way this has moved from one uh one year
to another year and what are the
differences that we saw in this um by by
students who have completed these
different topics are from coming from
one background in 2021 we see that there
is there was a lot of students from
b-tech biotechnology who joined the
program and completed the program they
were interested in oncology and
application of precision medicine they
applied a lot of genomics and
transcriptomics data analysis and worked
on different of research topics but by
2022 we saw that there has been more
applications there has been more
research areas there has been diverse
community of students who are joining
and working on their research projects
and these are all from
non-bioinformatics background these are
the students who have done uh who came
without any knowledge of coding without
any knowledge of you know
bioinformatics and they started from the
basic training and they went through the
pipeline where they
after doing after working from learning
about these different technologies
learning about this different
applications where this technology is
applied for example how genomics is
applied in precision medicine how a
transcriptomics data analysis is
utilized in uh oncology what are the
different
ways to look at the biomarkers in in
degenerative diseases where machine
learning is mostly applied and what kind
of data it applies to so there was a lot
of specialization training which was
involved in this internship period of
the students which was also from 45 days
to 90 days to 160 day to 120 days to six
months so we had this challenge where
students have different timelines but we
kind of created these different modules
through which we can
we can check their progress and see how
they are how they are moving from one
stage to another based on the timeline
they have registered to now the students
were able to complete some of these
projects that i am showing you in this
slide
so to highlight uh what the students
were able to achieve uh was one of the
one of the major outcomes so of this
research uh initiative of or this
collaborative initiative
where we have uh been able to record a
lot of this
data to be able to showcase or also the
students who were able to see this and
showcase their to their recruiters or to
their faculty and faculty can see their
progress so there is a progress link
associated with this training with every
student where we will if we where we've
been able to understand that what is the
level where the student is working on
what project he is doing or what what
kind of
expertise the student is developing
which is also open to the
to the
community and look for specific
expertise in these students now
another benefit that the students have
been able to achieve through this is to
be able to work on a real project now
this is a new project a noble project in
the sense that the data uh which we have
looked into
and also the research problems that we
have uh looked looked into are
specifically uh designed with the help
of the mentor and there were a lot of
discussion a lot of research uh
literature review before
opting for a specific pathway of uh to
go for the
use of the tools and the technologies
and also the different visualizations
and
other reporting which is required to
complete a project so i mean for the
students going through this entire
process of completing a project doing
going through these different steps of
research and then to be able to uh do a
presentation and do a bit do a
presentation and get that
acknowledgement that uh and also which
actually helps them to
build a better cgpa an entire
mark
entire growth that could be seen through
this project and also achieving the
brilliant results that they have been
able to do in a very short period of
time it was very rewarding and in this
in this in this entire symposium we will
have those opportunities to hear from
some of the students in our upcoming
session now uh these projects and uh the
focus is on different specializations as
we are discussing about precision
medicine we are discussing about
oncology so some students
with their pis have very specific ideas
to do uh maybe landscaping of cancer
immunotherapy which is a very broad
topic now uh
when we are looking at it and when we
start working on it and if it's a
collaborative project then the chances
of completing that project is is very
high because not only one person but
different different
students working together with the help
of a pi and the help of the
mentors at pine biotech now all of these
projects are published on omixlogic
learn and you are free to check out some
of these projects if you feel interested
and learn about these projects but this
omix symposium is also an opportunity to
learn from some of these experts who
have experience in this field and also
from these student examples that
examples that students have done so we
will have experts next
in this in this omics symposium day one
where we will be learning about the
relevance of omics so you saw that how
students have utilized different omics
technology and have completed a project
and we will be hearing from dr
naga soon
from about the relevance of
bioinformatics in omix and you will have
those questions ready and you can have
those questions ready that you have to
understand that how this is relevant in
studies or in understanding you know
some of these diseases that we see such
as the neurodegenerative diseases and
also at the same time here are some of
the links uh that students have been
able to work for example transcriptomics
analysis that they did on finding out
the
gene signatures regulating alzheimer's
diseases so looking at and working on
multi-dimensional data and applying
those algorithms such as principal
component analysis looking at the
gene expression and finding which are
the relevant and significant genes when
we are comparing two different states
and then looking at uh further doing the
downstream analysis leading to the
analysis of uh alzheimer's variant in
embryonic stem cell derived microglia so
this is a project that it's also an
example that you can take a look at so
uh again uh this is these are some of
the outcomes of the student-driven and
or the faculty-driven fellowships where
students have been able to work on
important topics such as precision
oncology we saw that as an example we
also saw
the use of
in in neuroscience now this is an
example of infectious diseases and this
is an example of surveillance of sar
scope to covet 19 variant of concern
from waste water samples based on the
ngs data and there's a recent article
that actually highlighted that how
important it is to do a genomic
surveillance and how important it is to
use the wastewater samples now this is a
practical experience what is happening
just happening in the industry just
happening in
that you see
around you and you have an opportunity
to work exactly on a similar research
use scientific tools and come up with
those
maybe find new insights find new
mutations those are some of the
opportunities that the faculty student
driven research fellowship was able to
provide to the students who worked with
us during this
with this partnership program with amity
university which is the case study that
i'm showing
you all
to highlight what we have achieved in
the last six months uh working with this
different
different students and as an opportunity
as you all are interested here and i see
this great enthusiasm and a lot of new
new participants joining and really
happy who are joining for the first time
that we will start our presentations
from the experts and we will have we
will be learning from uh experts from
iit delhi where we will discuss about dr
ishan gupta where we will discuss about
the kovid 19 pandemic and
his research on this similarly we are
discussing the research that students
have been able to do while uh they are
using uh this different types of data
types for example genetic and epigenetic
basis so genetic information epigenetic
information a multi-omics approach what
are these different approaches how do
you how do you learn about these
approaches and how do you apply this
into your own research or your you know
cv that you have learned this and
applied this so uh we have those
opportunities in today uh in today's
session where we will be learning about
the application of disease types complex
diseases use of multi-omics data from
experts who are going to be joining us
in and letting us know about their
research and uh what are the different
aspects that they have gone through
completing that research at the same
time yeah the students who have gone
through this entire uh experience
themselves will also get an opportunity
during the poster presentation
uh poster presentation session which is
coming up and really excited to uh to to
look for we are looking forward to the
session